What lights and yonder window breaks and
Juliet is the sun is the father. No, no,
no.
She's a bright ball of gas so someone's
son is Juliet is the star in the sky.
Oh world walking this here,
geology and this episode we're going to
build an AI reader that is an AI that
can analyze human language.
It's type of task is considered
natural language processing or NLP.
NLP is the arc of solving engineering
problems that need to analyze or generate
natural language text.
We see it all around us.
Google needs to do it to
understand exactly what your
search query means so they
can give you back relevant results.
Twitter uses it to extract
the top trending topics.
Microsoft uses it for Incar,
speech recognition and ops basically
extremely dope because it deals with
language. Kurzweil once said
that language is the key to AI.
A computer able to communicate
indistinguishably from
a human would be true.
Ai there 6,500 known languages in the
world and each of them have their own
rules for syntax and grammar.
Some rules are easy like I before e
except after c and some are based on
intuition.
Since there is no consistent use case.
So how do we write code
to analyze language?
Before the 80s NLP was mostly
just a bunch of hand coded rules.
Like if you see the word dance translated
to Zach do or if a word ends in ing,
label it as present tense.
Well this worked.
It was really tedious and
there are million corner cases.
It's just not a sustainable
path to language.
Understand the way forward
was an is machine learning.
So instead of hand coding the rules and
the AI learns the rules by analyzing a
large corpus or piece of text.
This is proven to be very useful and
applying deep learning to NLP is currently
the bleeding edge. So when thinking
about what tool to demo in this video,
I was really torn between an NLP API
called API to AI and Google is newly
released English parts or a
[inaudible]. Wow. Api Dot.
Ai Takes an input query and returns
and an analysis of the text Carsey has,
Google is newly released English parser.
Both have similar functionality,
but I'm going to go with Parsi because a,
it's currently the most
accurate parcer in the world be.
If you built it into your app, that's one
less networking call you have to make,
which means you can parse
tax offline and see.
Building this parsing logic from the
source allows you to have more granular
control over the details of how
you want text and be analyzed.
Parsi was built using syntax net,
an NLP neural net framework for Google's
tensorflow machine learning library,
so we could use syntax net to build our
own parser or we could use a pretrained
parser. Parsi. Yeah, let's do that.
Once you parsed your texts are a whole
host of things you can do with it.
Let's try it out with our own example.
We're going to build a simple python
app that uses parts of parse phase to
analyze a command by a user and
then repeat it back to them.
Both word is different.
We'll begin by importing our dependencies.
Then we'll set up our program to
receive in store that user input.
The input text has the Corpus.
We'll be analyzing.
We can get an array of all the part of
speech tags and the input text using the
Tagore function.
So what is part of speech tagging?
It's assigning grammatical labels
to each word in a given corporates,
you know all of those words we learned
back in elementary school to take the
phrase,
I saw her face and now I'm a believer.
If we tagged each word in that phrase
individually without looking at the
sentence as a whole,
we might tag saw as a certain bird,
which means this would be
a quote from Leatherface.
But if we look at this word in
the context of the sentence,
we realized that it's a different verb.
Google trained by interpreting sentences
from left to right for each word in the
sentence and the words around it.
They extracted a set of features
like the prefix and suffix,
put them into data blocks,
concatenated them altogether,
and fed them to a feed forward
neural net with lots of hidden lake,
which would then predict the probability
distribution over set a possible pos
tags and going in order from
left to right was useful.
Since they could use a previous words.
Tag has a feature in the next word.
So what does a parse tree,
what part of speech tagging isn't enough?
There's another part.
The meaning behind some piece of tax
isn't just the type of word that's being
used, but also how that word
relates to the rest of the sentence.
Take the example. Freights.
He fed her cat food.
There are three possibilities of what
this phrase could mean. Number one,
he had a woman's cats, some food. That's
the obvious one to us, intuitive humans,
but there's also a number two,
he found a woman.
Some food that was intended
for a cap or number three,
somehow encouraged some
cat boot to eat something.
The meaning of the sentence depends
on the context of each work.
The team use something called the head
modifier construction to sort ward
dependencies.
This generated directed arcs between
words like that and cat cat being a direct
object.
The word fat.
The sentence starts out unprocessed
with an initial stack of words.
The unprocessed segment
is called the buffer.
As the parser encounters words
as it moves from left to right,
it pushes words onto the stack.
Then it can do one of two things.
It can either pop two words off the stack
attached to the second to the first,
which would create a dependency arch
pointing to the left and push the first
word back on the stack or create an
arc pointing to the right and push the
second word back on the stack.
This will keep repeating until
the entire sentence is processed.
The system decides which way to point
the art depending on the context I. E.
Previous pos tagging.
Once that's done,
it uses the sequence of decisions to
learn a classifier that will predict
dependencies in a novel Corpus.
It applies a softmax function to each
of the decisions which normalizes or
adjust them to a common
scale and does this globally.
By summing up all the
softmax scores in log space.
So the neural net is able to give
probabilities for each possible decision.
And a heuristic called beam search helps
decide on the best one when predicting,
once we have our parse tree
and parts of speech variables,
let's store the root word and the
dependent object and to their own variable
will call us in an API to retrieve
a synonym for the dependent objects.
Then construct a novel sentence
that repeats the command
that users entered back
to them in different words.
Looks like it works pretty well.
The scope of what you can
do with this is so vast.
You can use this text analysis to create
a tech summarizer award recognizes the
intent of a query or understand if
a review is positive or negative,
or my personal favorite.
Create a political debate back
checker links with more info below,
please subscribe for more NL videos.
For now,
I've got to go fix a buffer overflow,
so thanks for watching.